Young Republicans are into weed related
weed is no longer cool partisan Tainan
marijuana legalization could be turning
with a new generation of millennial
Republicans a new Pew Research Center
survey has shown that nearly two-thirds
of those Americans between 18 and 35 who
identify as Republicans support
legalizing marijuana use group
conservative among Republicans age 35 to
50 with 47 percent favoring the
legalization of pot the percentage for
Democrats in this age group was 61%
alright so we've done a bajillion videos
on weed and every time we do a weed
video I always say that this should be a
Republican issue Republicans if you want
small government you wouldn't care what
someone's smoking in their bedroom and
you also wouldn't care whose someone's
sleeping with right so you want to sleep
with the gay guy go ahead we're
Republicans libertarians it supposed to
be about liberty but for some reason
it's almost as if the Republicans don't
believe the things that they're supposed
to but there's some hope here right
isn't isn't there actual hope here if
young Republicans are actually sticking
to the beliefs that they're supposed to
have well I think the key in that story
was identifying as Republicans because
I'm not sure that people who identify as
Republicans all the time understand what
it means to identify as a Republican so
one can we can we break that down like
that's so true that's what I always
that's what I keep saying about that I
think the Republicans they're doing
themselves a mage not that I'm trying to
help them but it seems like they're
doing themselves a major disservice I'm
not standing up for the things that
they're supposed to be for I mean a lot
of people are saying well I'm I'm a
Republican but I'm socially liberal
right like well that doesn't make you a
Republican that surely it should make
you a Republican right correct it by
definition I'm not sure you're a
Republican I mean I think that we have
some interesting definitions of our
social structure in our party structure
right entry but I I wonder with stuff
like that because we were like oh well
I'm pro-choice and I'm Pro gay rights
and gay marriage and I mean so when they
say there are we so when I say there
again so that really what they're saying
is they just want low taxes I made some
money and I'd like to hang on to it
right and the estate tax I know you love
the estate tax right state tax very
important my brother who makes $50,000
your worries about the estate at his
house out of nowhere he goes we got to
get rid of that I go what is the estate
tax because that's a few died you have
millions of dollars the government takes
half of it do you have a wealthy
relative we don't know about that's what
I told my bagon well let's let me know
when that becomes a problem
but until then turn off your AM radio
get invited to your own life yeah I'm
sure the estate tax is horrible but
estates don't have two cars that don't
work on the front yeah exactly
get that dryer fixed any day now yeah
the good news here though is that but
the weed thing is sailed right like
that's what I keep saying about the gay
thing it's you know it sounds like next
month or in a month and a half
no we prevail probably is going to
officially make gay marriage legal
throughout the country and even if they
fail on that it's going down
state-by-state it happened pretty quick
and it seems to me that weed is just
gonna follow suit right yeah I mean more
slowly it'll sit on the couch for a
while need some munchies I see what she
did whereas the gay issue it blew down
those states right yeah no we think it's
so stupid right you're a big you're a
big weed guy you have a weed card I have
a weed card I don't even smoke that much
weed but I have a weed card and it
really has it hasn't done any damage to
you what weed what I forgot you're
saying well listen I want to talk about
yeah of course not no I mean they've
done studies that there is no lethal
dose of marijuana there's a lethal dose
of caffeine nicotine sugar
there isn't a lethal dose of marijuana
it doesn't kill people it helps you can
get stupid high whatever don't kill you
sure sure I mean it's um you know just
like all things you know you wouldn't
drink a case of coca-cola and then try
to do needlepoint right so there are a
certain soda but that doesn't mean
coca-cola should be illegal or that it's
bad it's just you gotta use it correctly
same thing with marijuana there's a way
to use it it's hard to misuse marijuana
it's hard to make it be a detriment a
lot of time you'll hear those people who
eat marijuana and then they'll think
they're dying and they'll call them what
I think I'm dying right and then whether
they do I had a friend who went to the
emergency room yeah well what'd they
tell you they told me to just lay down
for a while right because that's
literally the
thing that's happening with marijuana
and the other thing that people don't
realize is that we incarcerate all these
people because of marijuana and this is
this is one of the things where to me
Obama has done a really bad job and he
even in this vice interview that he did
just this past week where they were
asking him most they took a poll from
the crowd and most people want to know
his feelings about marijuana and in some
ways he's been kind of good because
every time he gives a speech about
marijuana there's this like oh yeah I
used to smoke weed kind of thing on the
other hand he's still even now has the
feds closing I know dispensaries here in
California so to me this is where
another one of these things where he's
kind of played both sides it's not
wanting to alienate the older voters or
the more conservative voters yeah anyway
right so these are not just weak isn't a
two-term president with only 20 months
left it's not really important that she
can flat-out because what he said in the
Vice interview basically was well you
guys should be worried about other
things but that's not that's not a
leader that's just that's just playing
politics which I don't get when you're
left I'm saying how dare you hold me my
feet to the fire on an issue that's so
easily and clearly seen for me being
hypocritical and contradictory
about why would you would you please
stop bringing this up because it makes
me look bad it reveals me for being a
pure politician yes is exactly
what Barack Obama is just like everybody
is he's a pure politician and you say
why why what isn't it weak why would two
years left because if he started acting
courageous now why it up right six
years of being a cow tying
presenting Republican ideas by the way
right so that's why why did the
Republicans become so crazy as wing nut
party it's because the Democrats became
Republicans and the Republicans still
have to differentiate themselves in the
Democrats so when Barack Obama says he
will do your health care plan they have
to go we can't do ours now because you
want to do it right so wait
that's what we would compromise on so
I'm getting off track right yeah well I
think your point is that we they didn't
want to do Obama care so we did Romney
care we just called it away yeah we just
so there you go
anyway weed Republicans all that stuff
what do you think if they come around
would you consider voting Republican if
you're not a Republican right now let us
know I can still smoke weed without